-Our next guests
are the writers, producers,
and stars of the new movie
"Dicks: The Musical,"
which is in theaters
everywhere now.
Let's take a look.
-This is crazy, right?
-Totally crazy.
I mean, what are the odds
of working with
your long-lost twin?
-I don't know. 1 in 4, 3 in 4?
It's crazy.
-Crazy. But wait...
I can't believe Mom and Dad
split us up.
Like, is that abuse?
Did they abuse us?
-We definitely
experienced "abusement."
-Oh, my God.
-I mean, don't get me wrong.
My life is awesome.
-No, no, no, no, no.
M-M-Mine is awesome, too.
-I have an amazing job.
-Amazing job.
-Always dating
some big [Bleep] lady.
-Stunning big [Bleep] lady.
-I always get the things I want.
Except for a real family.
-Single-parent homes
are not real families.
That's true.
Hmm.
-Hmm.
-What do we do?
-Please welcome to the show
Aaron Jackson and Josh Sharp,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show,
gentlemen.
-Thank you.
-And congratulations
on this incredible film.
We've been lucky to have
some of your costars.
Bowen Yang was here,
the great Nathan Lane was here.
-Uh-huh.
-Yes.
-And then there are
some other --
Mega Mullally's in it.
Megan Thee Stallion is in it.
-Yeah, Thee Stallion
and Thee Mullally.
-Yeah, really, uh --
-You almost have,
like, the royal flush
of the whole cast.
-You did an incredible job.
It must be thrilling
to get people like that
to do this
very singular piece of work.
-Sure. That's a nice way
to say "crazy."
-[ Laughs ]
-So it is so deeply crazy.
Nathan Lane, who's done
so many crazy things,
basically said it's the craziest
thing he's ever done.
-A badge of honor
to hear that from Daddy.
-Yeah, truly,
we wear that with pride.
-So, this is a show you guys
used to do onstage at UCB?
-Yes.
-True.
-And I don't want to give
too much of the plot away,
but it is sort of
a "Parent Trap"-type film.
-It's true. We're using
"The Parent Trap" as a device
because it's really one of the
oldest story structures we have.
There's, like,
"Romeo and Juliet,"
"The Odyssey,"
and "The Parent Trap."
They're sort of accepted
narrative modalities.
-And you could see
from that clip,
we're sort of -- we're playing
heterosexual men.
But we are not heterosexual men.
-We're not.
-So it's actually
very brave and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Thank you.
-In fact, the opening
of the film,
just in case -- you're
not breaking news here,
because I believe
the opening of the film
has a title card
saying how brave it is.
-We want Oscars bad.
-Yes.
-And this is
how you win an Oscar.
-I believe you say
it's the first film
ever written by a gay writer.
-Yes.
-I know your show
has researchers.
We don't, so if that is wrong,
don't tell on us.
-Not on us.
How do we do, playing straight?
-Oh, my God,
it's so believable.
-Does it feel lived in?
-It felt very great. Thank you.
It was so nice to see,
finally,
it's, like, see
myself represented.
-Yeah, totally.
-You know what I mean?
-I know. I lived as straight
for like 18 years.
So it was Method,
the work I had done.
-It showed up.
It really showed up on-screen.
-You call them
"big [Bleep] ladies," right?
-We do.
-That's an industry term?
-We do -- industry, the fellas.
I mean, you -- of the many
things you had to do,
you actually wrote a rap and
then had to send the lyrics...
-Yes.
-...to Megan Thee Stallion.
-She's -- She's rapped before.
-Yeah.
And she's rather good at it.
-A lot of people say it's one
of the things she's known for.
-Yeah.
-I would say, top 4 or 5 things.
But then our gay asses
wrote a bunch of words,
and we're like,
"She won't say them."
And then she rapped
every single one of those words.
-There's, like --
There's amazing footage of Josh
just, like, rapping it
into a cellphone
to, like, send to her manager.
And then she just listened
to that rap
and was like,
"Great, I'll do it."
And when she showed up on-set,
she was like --
we were rehearsing --
she was like,
"I just want to say,
people say I'm dirty,
but y'all are dirty."
[ Laughter ]
-Profound badge of honor
to have Miss The Stallion
say, "You have done me right.
This is dirty."
-Do you have trepidation
when you send --
when you record a rap?
-Well, I was told
it would just go
to her manager and not her.
So I was hoodwinked.
And then she showed up
and was like,
"You got bars, young man."
-Yeah.
-So, what did you think?
Did you think the manager
would then rap it to her?
-I don't know what I thought.
I thought it was just like --
Really, we kept expecting her
to be -- to say no.
Every point, I was like,
"Someone will hear this
and go, "She's out.
She can't possibly do this."
-It's really wonderful,
because, you know --
and it's very early --
when she shows up,
she shows up with an energy
where she's like, "I am game.
I am in on this.
-She's so cool.
I mean, she was amazing.
-And now, Nathan Lane
talked about his scene partners
are the Sewer Boys.
I don't want to give too much
away about the Sewer Boys,
but he did bring them
on the show.
-Yeah.
-The Sewer Boys are
sort of a subterranean creatures
that he adopted
and keeps in his apartment.
-So beautiful and also pretty.
Gorgeous.
-Can I correct the record?
Everyone, including
on this program,
has called them puppets.
These are actors that we cast.
-Yeah, they came in,
they auditioned for the role.
They just brought something.
-They did a great --
So, Nathan brought them
to the show,
and then they actually
stuck around our offices.
-Yeah, they work hard.
-Hire them for admin.
-Hire them for admin
or for acting.
-They're so good at admin,
though.
-They are, they are.
-We read Chalamet for them.
-Yeah, Jennifer Lopez.
-Chalamet came in
for a Sewer Boy?
-Yeah.
-And he didn't get it?
-This close.
-They have the authenticity.
-He is very good.
-He read Fallon.
-Oh, really?
-He's mad.
That's why we're here.
-Oh, that's why you're here.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-There's some really -- So,
because, again, "Parent Trap,"
you then switch wigs,
or you switch hair.
So, it's wigs.
-Yeah.
-And they're even, I will say --
like, even Nathan's character
points out that the wigs --
it looks like a cheap wig.
-Yeah.
-It does not feel like you
maybe spent a ton of money
on the wigs in this film.
Here you guys are with opposite.
[ Laughter ]
So, I know this is both --
Look, this was a --
-Wait, could you even tell
that that was us playing?
-Who's to say?
-Could you even...
-Who is who?
-Now, when did you --
It is very funny
because, obviously,
the first time you guys
see each other in the movie,
you're taken aback
by how you look identical
to one another.
Do you remember the day when,
as young improvisers,
you first came up
with the idea of like,
"Wouldn't it be funny if we had
this as the jumping-off point?"
-Yeah, we were like, "For sure,
this will one day
become a movie."
-Yes, this is the normal,
like, how most movies are made.
You do them in the basement
of a grocery store,
and then that's
"Kramer vs. Kramer."
-Yeah, that was
started that way.
-Have your parents
seen the film?
-They have.
-And?
-They're, like,
very lovely Southern people
who you'd think
wouldn't like this,
and they love it.
And I think, furthermore,
they love that we have
health insurance.
-That's great.
-I think that is, like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys deserve it.
-[ Laughs ]
-And I also want to note
that the Sewer Boys,
which we had here
and then we returned to A24,
which made the film.
You wanted to keep --
-Oh, yes.
So, the last day of filming,
everyone keeps
calling them grotesque.
We find them to be beautiful.
-I don't see that.
-I don't see --
I don't see that.
And the last day of filming,
we had this whole plan.
We're like,
"We're gonna steal the puppets
so we can keep them."
A24 caught us.
They're like,
"You cannot do that.
We need them for reshoots.
They might one day
go on 'Seth.'"
And then they said,
"We promise you,
when this movie cycle is done,
you will get them.
No one [Bleep] wants them
but you."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's nice to know
they're finally gonna end up
in a loving home.
-Gonna be administration.
-Yes.
They're are assistants now.
-Guys, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-It's so much fun
to watch a film
that's unlike
anything I've ever seen.
And it's great to have you both.
-Thank you.
-And they're doing --
We were asked to say
they're doing sing-alongs.
-Sing-along screening.
-You guys are gonna do
sing-along screenings
of the movie.
That's gonna start this week?
-This week, they're doing
with the words on the screen.
This is up
for "Oppenheimer," too.
-Yes, us and "Oppenheimer."
-They're gonna do
a sing-along "Oppenheimer"?
-Yeah.
-Great. They should.
Thank you guys so much
for being here.
Aaron Jackson, Josh Sharp.
"Dicks: The Musical"
is in theaters,
and the soundtrack
is available now.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Late Night."